un jour deux hommes sont arrivés les
passer sur plus de vinay il venait d'un
temps où l'on croyait encore au diable
au sortilège aux potions magiques et
chamboule demi à tâter ce groupe et la
bijouterie du bouilh elles ne portent
pas cette relecture est le jour des ses
noces un seul sens est retournée comme
l'avait exigé l'enchanteur tu dois
respecter la loi
l'autre je suis jacquot lieux jacques
assez bien envoyé son descendant à sa
place au moyen-âge support est à vous
envoyer un gros chèque de cotisation des
jeux serait rentré chez moi
on va chez dame béatrice son père est
vivant à 28 là je t'aime ma petite fille
au pair
l'athlète cintres hollande
il a ainsi porté chine sont enfermés les
couloirs du temps ce sont des choses que
personne ne veut croire et qui coûte
très cher et sans racines
si les couloirs du temps reste béant
alors les pires malédiction s'abattront
sur cette terre